Django Reinhardt sur un flanc Molière
sur l'autre et dit est un camion un peu
spécial aménagé il y a tout juste cinq
mois il a des airs de centre d'animation
alors on va commencer ici par l'espace
bibliothèque qui du coup va être équipé
de livres essentiellement orientés vers
les arts du spectacle là on arrive sur
un mur qui va permettre de mettre des
étagères en fait pour pouvoir exposer
des objets
au fond ici on a l'espace de scène donc
on a quatre projecteurs donc deux
enfants de Seine et deux en avant scène
qui se trouvent juste là et donc pour
les spectacles qui seront des formats
courts les artistes pourront se mettre
ici et donc là sur ce mur on va pouvoir
mettre des tableaux donc il est plutôt
dédié aux expositions faire rimer
culture et réinsertion professionnelle
c'est le pari un peu fou que s'est lancé
Alex à d'argent ancien dirigeant d'une
compagnie de théâtre il est à la tête de
l'entreprise le bazar culturel un
théâtre social itinérant qui propose
plusieurs services le conseil et la
formation c'est vraiment tout ce qui est
dédié au recrutement et au bilan de
compétences la médiation ça va être les
équipements qui sont dans le camion sur
le volet activité on va proposer des
ateliers des projections de films des
expositions des conférences et des
escape game et sur le volet spectacle le
vivant ça va être les créations plus
artistiques donc avec du théâtre
notamment c'est un projet que je suis en
train de monter actuellement qui existe
donc là depuis le mois de septembre 2022
et l'origine est très simple en fait moi
j'ai un a parcours dans le spectacle
vivant et j'avais envie d'un projet qui
me permet d'aller plus à la rencontre
des publics son objectif rendre la
culture accessible tout en accompagnant
vers l'autonomie c'est très important je
pense de mettre la culture au service
d'alimentation puisque c'est ce qui
permet en fait à chacun de révéler son
plein potentiel et donc l'idée d'aller
m'adresser à des personnes qui étaient
plutôt en recherche d'emploi c'est que
forcément on est sur des publics qui
sont peut-être un peu plus vulnérables
collectivités particuliers entreprises à
l'ex répond à toutes les demandes dans
le sud-yvelines et l'Eure-et-Loir son
activité s'est lancée officiellement en
octobre prochain rendez-vous le
spectacle la mortais d'après Maupassant
le samedi 5 novembre au court-bouillon à
Rambouillet